what problems does material design try
to solve well the question of you know
how a user goes between all these
different devices is a key one you know
to the user it's really just they're
doing this one task they're trying to do
this one thing and it doesn't matter so
much for them whether it happens to be
on the phone in their pocket or the
laptop that's on their desk so we want
that kind of continuity something else
we really focus on is motion you know we
we've seen all too often that motion is
something that just kind of gets tacked
on at the end right so you do all this
other work and then you just kind of add
in some animation after effect or
something like that it is literally that
right it's like it's all done some throw
that thing in there now we try to think
about motion from the very start because
we think that kind of knowing how things
are going to move around is so powerful
for giving feedback to the user about
what they're doing so you want to kind
of plan for that in advance and we try
to have these materials that give the
material design its name are things like
kind of paper and ink that can kind of
move in predictable ways that feel
tactile and feel familiar to the user
but aren't bound by kind of boring old
reality and they can do kind of these
really interesting things that makes the
user feel powerful and you know that's a
key goal towards giving them a
satisfying experience so the inspiration
comes from design and material actual
material not in to Playland
yeah I mean we really wanted to look at
things that felt familiar to the user
and we engage with those materials every
day we don't engage with kind of these
pieces of inscrutable glass but in our
day to day life except when we're using
these devices so why should that be the
metaphor let's go for something that's a
little bit more predictable so where do
I as an entrepreneur come to learn more
about the material design the best place
to start is just google.com slash design
so from that site we have a full
specification a set of guidelines that
describes material design it breaks down
the kind of philosophy behind it gives
you some key principles to employ it's
richly illustrated with imagery with
motion sample
of video and also has a lot of resources
that you can download so fonts color
palettes sticker sheets of kind of
common components for all of the typical
design tools that you might use so I can
use those out of the box and not invent
reinvent the wheel right
exactly and then it should be very close
to what you're getting on the platforms
that directly support material